you did something about being tortured
and like waterboarding just to show like
those are different things
what where you said you did this thing
about being tortured and waterboarding
but you like
colluded those two yeah those are
different things yeah waterboarding is
not tortured yeah that's literally what
I was showing yeah because I always
wanted to film a video with Steve like
going through like different like board
he would be bored if you waterboarded
him he'd be like
then why do people like I'm barely
uncomfortable it uh it's kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it is it's not I'm not gonna
say that it wouldn't be uncomfortable
but I just don't think it's visually
like impressive or shocking to it is
uncomfortable yeah but you are very
familiar with this Comfort yeah it's
kind of like being it's like jumping in
the water and you don't play yeah it is
not a thing it um I mean I was I was
waterboarded I you know like there's
really strict guidelines as to what
you're allowed to do when you're
waterboarding
um in this this is the rules of engage
like the rules of what like War when you
capture somebody no so all forms of
enhanced interrogation and that's what
waterboarding was
um and they don't do it anymore so
there's there's a bunch of enhanced
interrogation techniques but techniques
there's a really clear Sops like this is
how you do it this is how it's safe to
do it so you don't draw found somebody
or hurt somebody and there's also useful
information so real information is
something that's dependable reliable and
usable if you're pulling somebody's
fingernails out and drilling their hands
you know does that enhanced
interrogation that is not that's torture
okay and there's no information there
because there that person would say
anything to get out of this and to get
out of torture uh you know like my mom's
a goose the sky is purple you're right
my mom yeah my mom goose and this guy's
purple you're like whatever so that the
that's the fine balance of in enhanced
irrigation finding truth and but
goal is to put somebody under a really
serious external stressors that are
constant so that you can decipher truth
from fallacy
and if you don't have a
status if you don't have a baseline
there's no way that you'd ever be able
to gauge truthfulness from a lie what
about a lie detector test
um that doesn't always helpful
and when you are trying it's like yes no
questions lie detector tests and and you
know voice stress analyzers polygraphs
um those can be useful and when the
American Military and government does it
on us for our security clearances
um they're like yes nose like
um are you an agent for a for a foreign
entity
no you know do you have any business
relationships with Russian agents no
like really easy but we also have bass
lines where they know and that's that's
like developed over time so it's not in
the field or it's baselines meaning like
your Biometrics that they know who you
are and like he's always at a 70 for
some reason is that at 82 heartbeats per
minute like that's weird yeah that's
interesting and in like high stress
situations with enhanced
uh interrogation yeah they call it bit
or TQ bit Battlefield interrogation
techniques for TQ is tactical
questioning and in in like an initial
like if I first get a bad guy there
there are
more relaxed rules initially during the
initial time that we take this person in
to ask really relevant important
questions about saving and protecting
people's lives like specifically are
there any current operations that are
targeting
um you know Americans or their allies in
this region you know that line of
questioning
um and it's it's intense initially
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude